Uh, my name is Suaad Alshleh. I am a
student at the Royal College of Surgeons in Ireland and i'm 18 years old.
When President von der Leyen mentioned me in her speech,
I was incredibly surprised
but also very honoured and grateful, you know,
to be mentioned by the most powerful person in Europe.
And we will make sure that people who have the right to stay are integrated and made to feel welcome.
They have a future to build and skills, energy and talent.
I think of Suaad, the teenage Syrian refugee who arrived in Europe dreaming of being a medical doctor.
Within 3 years, she was awarded a prestigious scholarship
from the Royal College of Surgeons in Ireland.
I’ve always wanted to be a doctor.
I suppose because the idea of being able to help others
when they’re most vulnerable, that appeals to me a lot,
along with the science and the knowledge
behind being a doctor.
I could check the first line and I could see that I had an offer to RCSI
and I genuinely started jumping up and down.
And I called my parents, called them to come over, and it was, you know,
that one moment where you feel like everything you’ve worked hard for has paid off.
And I genuinely, you know my heart couldn’t stop beating
and I was just so happy.
So, yeah, that was probably
my happiest moment so far in Ireland.
When I first came to Ireland,
obviously it was a period of great change for me.
Everything from the simple things,
like the weather, was different.
But I met a lot of people that made Ireland feel like home,
be it my friends from the schools I went to and even my friends at College now.
So I can safely say Ireland is my home
and I am used to the weather, crazy as it may be.
Yeah, I’m really happy to be here.